Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you ruffians for being here, waking up early for our 34th episode!
BAU BAU!
I saw there was a couple ruffians saying that maybe this was their first time watching live today.
Or their first time watching in a long time.
Which reminds you, FUWAMOCO- It's a very serious matter.
Very serious, okay?
Make sure you get it.
No misunderstandings, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, today, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And is hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, how are you feeling today?
You're feeling... Awake.
Excited.
Awake.
Frightened.
There was a Pero Sighting?
Oi!
I see you.
Hopefully not a very scary one.
Not a scary one.
Not a vicious one.
No vicious.
Let's see.
De-den!
A special flying dog?
This is a bit of a surprising sighting.
Right!
Pero just swooped on in and started staring at you deliously.
You better do something before he messes with your plants.
You don't want him to push them over, right?
You know, I have a few little succulents.
And I always have to keep an eye on Pero so he doesn't do anything to them too, you know?
But you know, there's the owl plant, right?
FUWAMOCO-chan's plant.
Yeah, and succulents can look pretty yummy too, right?
You know, Pero keeps on saying that if I'm not careful he's gonna take a big bite out of them.
So, hopefully, he doesn't do anything like that to your butt.
Okay?
But you know, the joke's on him, cause if he does, he'll just get violently sick!
Ruffians, don't hit us with that if we ever decide to get nice and close to your plants, okay?
I don't want to get bonked by the shoe, okay?
Don't bonk us with your shoe, Ruffians.
But shoes and slippers are the best against unwanted pests, though, right?
It is.
You know an unwanted pest?
I guess.
He's good at biting plants, you know.
Yeah, he's a pest.
But we were taught this secret method between guard dogs here in Japan and
Since then, we've never done anything else.
This is it.
This is the method.
I think some ruffians know that I don't really like socks.
And I have slippers, but they're rarely used for my feet.
BAU BAU!
Well, we'd actually like to invite you to our Advent Halloween Party!
BAU BAU BAU!
Ruffians, I see a lot of noise.
I'm concerned.
We invited you already.
We invited you already, you didn't forget about our invitation.
You didn't forget, right.
We invited you.
I'm really concerned, Moco-chan.
Right.
Well, ruffians, now you have plans, okay?
We have plans!
There is plans, you have plans!
Because this year, we're having a Halloween party!
A special costume party too!
A lot of ruffians have been designing outfits for us, right?
I'm really happy!
But you haven't forgotten about yourself too, right?
You need to have a costume for yourself too, you know.
It's a costume party.
Please don't forget to share your hololive themed costumes with the hashtag Advent Costume Party on Twitter.
And you know what?
All of Advent, we might review it during our party.
That would be pretty cool, right?
You know, it doesn't even need to be anything amazing at all.
Nothing fancy.
We just want to see your love and passion, right?
Just that, you know.
You know you could dress up as a pebble, right?
Or a petal like I mentioned yesterday, too.
Or even like a FUWAMOCO-themed outfit, right?
You know, we've got some...
Please share them with us, okay?
We're waiting!
BAU BAU!
I'm excited for you.
Lots of Halloween stories.
But not Halloween related.
Ruffians, Moco-chan has something to confess to you.
Something kind of...
Really, really, really embarrassing.
And, you know, Moco-chan, she's been kind of thinking about whether she should share it with you for a long time now.
It sounds like you're pretty happy, huh?
Me?
No, but, you know, it's been, it's been weighing on your chest.
It's been really, really embarrassing!
It's been weighing on your chest and, you know, it might be good to feel FU afterwards, you know?
Yeah.
But it's... You don't want anything weighing on my chest?
Wow, Moco-chan.
Please, yeah.
Feel free, feel free, you know?
Freedom waits.
BAU!
You know... It might be a bit surprising, but... I'm actually really afraid of big dogs.
Yeah.
You know, any dog that's bigger than me, for some reason, I don't really know why, but maybe they feel the fear from me.
But they seem to like me in particular compared to Fuwawa.
It's really embarrassing.
You know, even when I try to sneak away from any big dogs approaching me when we go on our walks, they always end up running up to me and it makes me scared so I flinch and then hide behind Fuwawa.
It's embarrassing for me too, Ruffians.
I'm sure the owner thinks I'm pretty funny, huh?
Yeah.
No.
Smaller dogs.
Okay.
Medium dogs.
Extremely fluffy big dogs.
Maybe okay if they have good manners.
Okay.
But for most big dogs, I like to keep my distance.
I'm sorry if your doggy is a big dog.
I like to keep a good distance between us until I'm used to them.
Then we can be friends.
But until then, I'd like them to stay away from me.
It makes me nervous.
But you know, Ruffians!
Don't misunderstand, okay?
Because I'm a tough, big, demon guard dog, okay?
Don't misunderstand!
I'm big.
I'm big!
Got it.
Got it!
Yeah, right!
Tough puppy.
I'm tough!
I'm rough!
I'm big!
Got it.
BAU BAU!
Do you feel better, Moco-chan?
The ruffians don't understand.
That makes me feel unhappy.
I'll give a ruffian some time and I should've come around, right?
You'll come around?
Yeah.
Did you say so?
I opened my heart.
You did.
I should've come around.
I'll accept it, okay?
It's not a question, it's an answer.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, we have some happy news!
Happy news!
Now that Moco-chan's confessed, you feel a little bit lighter.
Well, we can share some good news!
Happy news!
Ruffians, Papa Puppy came by yesterday.
And he came by with his two kids, too!
And guess what?
Guess what?
Moco-chan's chair is REVISED!
I have my arm back!
It's huge!
Moco-chan even found all the screws for the chair too!
I'm amazing!
I have them all!
It's arm is back.
It's fixed.
For now, as Puppapuppi put it very ominously, he was actually even surprised that the other arm hadn't fallen off yet too.
Actually, he did break a tool in the process of fixing it.
There is a sacrifice for the revival of it.
Let's see maybe how many Donkey Kong Country themes it will take until it breaks?
Maybe?
Can we not do that?
It'll be okay.
How many more Donkey Kong Country sims do we even have?
We're almost done, right?
I don't know, we go pretty bananas.
The chair will be okay.
BAU BAU!
Happy new, happy news!
Welcome back, chair arm.
BAU BAU!
It's weird having the orange back, but it's happy.
More happy stuff, right?
Ruffians!
You were there with us early yesterday when we played Horo no Suika, right?
It was a lot of fun, right?
It was fun.
Right!
High score!
So, we feel like we need to clear things up so that no more misunderstandings.
Well, our beloved senpai was there, right?
And Moco-chan might have accidentally said things like, you know, we have to get rid of this senpai or there's a lot of garbage.
Referring to our senpai.
Moco-chan, it's just all a misunderstanding, right?
It's a misunderstanding!
You know, it's garbage in an affectionate way.
That's the way you use it.
Yeah, like garbage can make a lot of amazing things, right?
Like jewelry and...
You're just garbage to me!
Ruffians, you're good with that, right?
But see, this is exactly it.
Ruffians, you understand, right?
That's why garbage is an endearing term.
Yeah, just like useless.
I say that a lot when playing games.
You're useless.
You called me useless before too, but it's endearing.
But I like you.
No misunderstandings!
It's good.
We love A.I.
Senpai very much.
Lots of respect.
That's A.I.
Senpai, okay?
No misunderstandings!
BAU BAU!
You love garbage.
The ruffians are garbage.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Raspberries.
Frozen raspberries.
And you take this.
You add some milk.
And then you get this!
Yummy!
Frozen raspberries and milk!
You crush them up and put milk on it.
And then it becomes like an ice cream.
It's so yummy!
It's very good.
We've been a bit addicted to it recently.
Yeah.
We really like sweet and sour things.
Raspberries are just that.
Yeah!
Moco-chan has to have her own bag, and I have to have my own bag too.
There's no confusion, and no one steals each other's raspberries when they're not looking.
I know there's the ice cream machines, but it's fine, just using arm power, you know.
Squish squish squish squish squish squish squish squish.
Yeah, and then just mix it all up.
Ice cream.
Do you think you'll try it, Ruffian?
Never tried it, but it sounds delicious.
It is!
You should try it!
Honey!
You don't need honey for it.
No honey.
Just milk and raspberries.
Right, the raspberries.
Soy milk!
Not soy milk, maybe.
Something a bit more milky.
A bit more milky.
Yeah, it's almost like a milkshake, but ice cream.
Right.
You should try it.
Yeah, it's oishii.
It's oishii.
Yes.
We recommend.
Yes, our big recommendation of today, Friday.
Friday is Frozen Raspberry Day.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's move on to our regular corner, Moco-chan.
Today we have another Doggie of the Day!
Who's the doggy today?
De-den!
It's Hazel!
She's 13 years old and pretty cranky.
I guess 13 years of wisdom can get someone pretty cranky.
But here she is.
She's here with her favorite hot dog toy.
Hot dog.
She wants her privacy.
Don't get too close to her and her favorite toy, right?
She does look a bit big.
But she also sort of looks like a hot dog.
A spicy hot dog.
Cute.
How does she BAU BAU?
You know, maybe like a BAU BAU and she's really excited for her hotdog?
You know like... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Give me the hotdog BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Like that?
Yeah.
I'm sure, yes.
That's why her crankiness is good.
She can protect you.
She can help, you know?
It's good.
Crankiness is extra protection skill.
It's a good thing.
Yeah, but just make sure that you don't get in between her and her hotdog time.
No, no, no.
Precious hotdog time.
Precious hotdog.
Don't touch.
BAU BAU!
Did a ruffian go on to a nice walk?
Let's see!
De-den!
Is this a painting?
Is this real?
Is this real life?
It's beautiful!
It's really, really beautiful.
Why didn't you just stop there and live there forever?
It's so pretty, right?
I think I would just cry if I saw this in real life.
Sights like this make you really grateful for the passing seasons and passing time.
Right!
It makes you feel alive too!
Too many bugs, that's not important.
It's beautiful.
Don't worry about the bugs when it's this beautiful.
I think this probably has to be one of the best wall shots from the ruffians so far.
It's really beautiful.
Right?
All those leaves, every single leaf is yellow.
And then the blue skies.
It's amazing.
A beautiful walk indeed.
Hopefully we can go on more walks here.
It's very nice.
BAU BAU!
And finally, for our question of the day!
We have... De-den!
How long did it take you to decide on Ruffians as your fan name while you were in the cell?
Are you able to share any of the other names you were considering before deciding?
It took us a little while to figure it out, but I think Moco-chan, you mentioned it before?
I mentioned it before, just a little bit.
But it was the first thing that came to Moco-chan's mind when she woke up one moment.
Yeah!
I woke up.
I literally woke up.
And then I was like, ruffians.
Even before she said good morning or anything to me.
But before that we had some ideas.
Fluffer, fluffer was one of them.
But Mari-chan said it's not the best.
Yeah, because you know, when you fluzzers right, it has to be equal so it doesn't work.
Ruffians.
Abyssians.
Doggie Pack.
It's a very warm winter's night.
I think it's only ruffians.
Very rough, very soft.
Special.
BAU BAU!
We like ruffians too because you're a ruffian so you can't change that.
What about kerfluffians though?
Kerfluffians?
Kerfluffians!
Doggy, doggy, doggy days.
Thank you everyone.
Please don't forget to use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
You thought too.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Our next stream, we have another stream coming up.
We got a new job, ruffians!
Our job is... We have two jobs now.
To protect your smile, and we have to work...
Part-time at the convenience store.
Do we at least get to sample the new products?
Do we get to have the food that's left over and gonna expire?
That would be nice, no?
Yeah.
If we do that, can we get promoted to tengchou?
By eating the leftover food?
I guess it helps with waste.
Yeah!
But we'll do our best, ruffians!
We'll do our best to make every customer that comes in smile!
Yeah!
This is our convenience store!
And you too!
We need to make a lasting impression.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Rock n' Rawr Party!
We're excited!
We're hyped!
It's gonna be very spooky and silly.
You know we're gonna sing a lot of songs that make us feel a bit of shiver when we hear them.
Shiver.
So we hope that you feel that way too.
We're gonna make the ruffians shiver.
We're gonna make the hair on your arms stand up.
Maybe.
Do we have like a recommended drink of choice for the moment?
To enjoy while walking or partying?
It's a Halloween special, so... I guess apple juice or apple cider?
Yummy full tasting!
But we're really excited because we'll be singing a few songs that we really didn't think we'd ever be able to sing for you!
We prepared specially!
Yeah, we prepared them specially so that we could sing them for you.
Made specifically for FUWAMOCO.
Yeah.
It sounds really good.
BAU BAU!
We've reached the end of the week!
The end of FUWAMOCO Morning!
We did it!
The end of the week, ruffians!
Ruffians, thank you so much for joining us today for the 34th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special ruffians!
Jacket.
BAU BAU!
Fleece.
Scissor.
BAU BAU!
John.
Marina.
BAU BAU!
Denten.
Ellipse.
Nosecap.
BAU BAU!
Ellipsis.
KSP.
BAU BAU!
Poor RNG.
Every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!